Speaker 1: There is a new report that former
President Donald Trump is now actively working
to remove Mitch McConnell as the leader of
Republicans in the Senate.
Now, what's funny is Trump's worth.
That work ethic we learned with him as president
is a disaster.
So the fact that Trump believes is believed
to be actively working toward something may
not really mean very much.
But regardless, let's talk about what is being
reported at this point in time.
Business Insider reporting Trump is actively
working to oust McConnell as the Senate Republican
leader.
Now, remember, because Republicans don't currently
control the Senate, Mitch is the Senate minority
leader rather than the Senate majority leader.
OK, just just a point of clarification to
ensure that we have clarity this evening.
Former President Donald Trump has spoken recently
with Republican senators and political allies
about ousting Minority Leader Mitch McConnell
from leadership and is gauging whether there's
any interest among lawmakers for a possible
challenge, according to The Wall Street Journal.
There appears to be little support for such
a drastic move, according to the report.
But Trump's actions could potentially morph
into a larger issue for the party, especially
as the Kentucky Republican hopes to regain
the Senate majority in the 2022 midterm elections.
And the former president continues to float
a potential 2024 bid.
So you have these two factors coming together.
You have Republicans want the Senate back
in 2002, and there doesn't seem to be much
of an appetite from the base to remove Mitch
McConnell as the leader.
On the other hand, Donald Trump is thinking
about a run in 2020 for Mitch McConnell, at
least over the last nine months, has not been
a particularly big friend to Trump ism.
And you have this conflict.
Which way are they more likely to go?
While Trump and McConnell worked together
to fill scores of federal court vacancies
and with conservative jurists, along with
passing the Tax Cuts and Jobs Act and other
Republican priorities, Trump's intransigence
in accepting his election loss to now President
Joe Biden and the January six capital riot
deeply strained the relationship between the
two men.
That sort of an understatement in the sense
that at every rally Trump has done recently,
which we've covered just about all of them,
he actively goes after Mitch McConnell and
so-called Renaults and talks about how bad
actually Mitch McConnell has been.
Rarely.
Let me put a different way.
I don't want to say rarely.
I don't remember even a single instance of
a current or former Republican president being
this hostile to a Republican Senate leader.
It's not even that it's rare.
I just don't remember any other instance.
I'm glad to be reminded of one if you're aware
of one.
The article goes on to say, After Trump's
second Senate impeachment trial for incitement
of insurrection for his role in the riot,
McConnell declined to find the president guilty,
but sharply rebuked him on the Senate floor.
Later, McConnell said he would support Trump
in twenty four if he were the nominee.
But Trump has not forgiven the minority leader
for his speech.
Trump has continued to needle McConnell in
the press.
He recently took the minority leader to task
for backing the one point two trillion dollar
bipartisan infrastructure package that passed
the Senate last month, calling the legislation
a disgrace.
Trump saying, quote, If Mitch McConnell was
smart, which we've seen no evidence of, he
would use the debt ceiling card to negotiate
a good infrastructure package.
We'll actually talk a little bit about that
on the bonus show today as well.
So let's see how the base reacts.
I welcome the self cannibalization or I guess
you don't have to say it's just the cannibalization
self cannibals.
Well, you guys know what I mean.
I welcome the Republican Party eating itself
so far, the base which supports Trump has
certainly cheered on Trump's attacks on other
Republicans, at least his rallies at rallies.
But a lot of those rally goers are confused
by what's going on.
They don't know, you know, lefties down, whatever.
They don't know what's going on.
They would probably cheer whatever Trump says.
It's not clear they actually are understanding
what they're doing.
But we could see a change in the interest
of the Trump wing of the Republican Party
in supporting Trump's attacks on the establishment
Republican Party in particular, if Trump ism
doesn't do well in the midterms in terms of
ousting McConnell.
McConnell was just reelected in 2020.
He's there until twenty twenty six.
I have a difficult time thinking that Republicans
will really turn on him as long as something
completely insane isn't found in McConnell's
closet.
I actually am hoping Trump succeeds at creating
chaos and hostility against McConnell in a
more serious way among the Republican establishment.
I just don't think he can do that much.
But anything he's able to do is likely to
fracture the Republican Party.
And that's a really great thing.
It would be terrible for Republicans in the
upcoming midterms to be fighting each other
as much as they're fighting Democrats.
It would be great for Democrats, for Republicans
to be fighting each other.
It's just really not clear at this point to
what degree Donald Trump can get Republicans
angry against other Republicans in a way that
will actually have electoral consequences.
I just don't know the answer to that now.
This Saturday, Trump is doing a rally in I
believe it's in Georgia.
My plan is to cover it technology permitting
and schedule permitting.
We will see to what degree Trump attacks Republicans.
And the location of this rally in Georgia
is actually very important.
Donald Trump, we talked yesterday, just released
this letter written to officials in Georgia.
All Republicans remember demanding that the
rightful winner of the 2020 presidential election
in Georgia be announced.
Trump means himself by saying that.
And there's a very good chance, in particular
with Saturday's rally being in Georgia, that
Trump will go really hard against the Republicans
in that state.
It'll be interesting, particularly in light
of the Mitch McConnell plan that Trump is
developing and, you know, plan maybe a bit
of a generous term.
It'll be interesting to see to what degree
the crowd cheers Trump's attacks on Republicans.
So that's Saturday.
In the meantime, tell me this.
Find me on Twitter at that department and
tell me this.
Do you really think Republicans might turn
on Mitch McConnell?
I have a very difficult time seeing.
Let me know.